what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be talking about um
a topic that i don't think
really is spoke about enough in the man
of sphere um but before i start do not
forget
to subscribe to the channel and bring
that notification bell the way you're
going to be notified of my daily videos
okay so today i'm going to be talking
about exceptions
um i know everybody um
will always say i know that one person
that like dated totally out of their
league or
you know i know that one girl that makes
more money than her husband or whatever
the exception is to the rule
and we see it i think more often than
the man of sphere really gives credit to
because like you know people are people
and there's always going to be
exceptions when it comes to people
but i i got to thinking like why do
people make exceptions for some people
like a woman or a man has a list of like
things they want
right like for example i think in
general men
don't want to date single mothers but i
know a lot of single mothers that got
remarried
um or you know
ended up getting married later to a
different guy
and i think a lot of the time
those exceptions are made because
you have common interests and this is an
example that i thought of like a couple
years ago
um i went on a date a couple dates with
this guy like i was dating him for maybe
like a month
and i didn't end up like continuing to
see him and one of the reasons
was because honestly like he the [ __ ] he
wanted to do
i just did not want to do like he did
like
ultra marathons wanted to go camping
every weekend like super outdoorsy
and like it's just i'm somewhat
outdoorsy like couple times a year i'd
love to go for a nice hike whatever but
it's just not something i'm gonna be
doing every weekend
and a guy like that might date a girl
that might not necessarily have
everything on his list but is willing to
do
all the things he likes to do with him
and common interests like
seriously as a girl like dating guys
like gets you so far
just liking to do the same thing being
interested in the same thing
and people want to say that's not a
value like you can't build a marriage
off of that but like
what you like to do throughout a
lifetime takes up a lot of time and
the reason that i think my parents are
so good together is because they both
are one hard workers
and two they genuinely like like doing a
lot of the same things like they like to
ski
they like to um go on trips together and
like
a lot of stuff that could have been a
fight for other couples for like what
they would do with their weekends
really wasn't a fight for them because
they like doing the same thing so
let me know in the comments if you guys
agree or you disagree
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and bring that notification bell that
way you're going to be notified of my
daily videos and i will talk to you guys
next time